a coffee filters job is pretty simple
hold back the large bitter grounds and
let the liquid coffee through scientists
have now invented a new technique that
flips the script holding back small
particles but letting larger ones pass
instead of sorting particles by size
this reverse filter sorts them by
kinetic energy larger heavier objects
with more force break through the
barrier while lighter slower objects
don't inspired by the process of
phagocytosis when our cells swallow
foreign objects the barrier itself is
made of a self-healing liquid similar to
a cell membrane to make the magical
membrane researchers need only a metal
ring and two ingredients deionized water
and sodium dodecyl sulfate or SDS a
compound commonly used in laundry
detergent when researchers tested their
filter they found it could be repeatedly
penetrated without rupturing even after
three hours of constant product it could
also hold back gas while letting bigger
objects through and even kept the lid on
a beaker full of scrambling fruit flies
and by varying the concentrations of SDS
scientists could finally tune the
surface tension of the membrane the key
to its remarkable abilities at very high
levels of tension only the larger or
faster moving particles make it through
before the liquid seals together again
but at low levels of tension smaller or
slower moving particles can do the same
thing that means scientists could use it
in a variety of ways there's a surgical
membrane that blocks out dust and germs
a barrier against infection transmitting
insects even as a thin film that could
trap odors in a waterless toilet
what's more the membrane is
self-cleaning small trapped particles
are easily transported across it's
slanting surface and off to the side
keeping the membrane free of
contaminants the resulting filter may
make for more successful surgeries and
better odor eaters if you want the
perfect cup of joe
stick to an old-fashioned filter
[Music]
you
[Music]